con un retraso de un año debido a la
pandemia de koi 19 la cumbre climática
celebra su edición número 26 en escocia
el presidente de la cob 26 abrió el
encuentro refiriéndose al principal
objetivo limitar a 1,5 grados
centígrados el calentamiento global como
fue pactado en la cumbre climática
celebrada en 2015 en francia
el clima rápidamente cambiante está
haciendo sonar una alarma para que el
mundo intensifique su adaptación para
abordar las pérdidas y los daños y para
actuar ahora para mantener vivo el
límite de 15 grados de tesco
y sabemos que está con 26 es nuestra
última mejor esperanza para mantener ese
nivel de 1,5 grados a nuestro alcance
durante el encuentro también se
necesitará asegurar acciones para
reducir las emisiones de gases de efecto
invernadero
el financiamiento climático y terminar
las normas para implementar el acuerdo
de parís desde el vaticano el papa
francisco hizo un llamado a los
asistentes de la cumbre pero llamó a fin
que el querido de la tierra rezamos para
que se escuche el grito de la tierra
de los pobres y que esta reunión
proporcione respuestas eficaces que
ofrezcan una respuesta real a las
generaciones futuras en el futuro
ambientalistas manifestaron en las
calles de bruselas y roma con el fin de
presionar a los líderes reunidos en
escocia para que dejen de hacer promesas
vacías que tanto han caracterizado a
gran parte de la política climática
global aunque en los últimos años los
países han asumido nuevos compromisos la
onu asegura que el mundo se precipita
hacia un peligroso aumento de la
temperatura global de al menos 27 grados
centígrados en este siglo los expertos
aseguran además que este cambio
climático amenazar a la vida en el
planeta en las próximas tres décadas